Dr. Burke here. Today we're going to
talk about things that you should never
put on your face. Now, being in practice
for 30 years, I've seen it all. So many
people are using things on their face
that are very dangerous. But there are
11 things that you have to be very
careful of. And some of the things I
want to share with you can put on your
face, but you really need to know what
you're doing. Your skin is the largest
organ in your entire body. A lot of
surface area. And on top of the skin,
especially on your face, you have what's
called an acid mantle. Now, what's that?
That's a protective barrier that
involves a certain pH that's slightly
acidic. So, in other words, your skin is
not neutral. It's not basic or alkaline.
It's acidic. And so, if we go from
neutral 7 to a six, that's 10 times more
acidic. And then from 6 to 5, that's
another 10 times more acidic. Well, the
skin is between 4.5 and 5.5. So, it's
pretty acidic. And the reason why it's
acidic is you have microbes that are
making it acidic. So you have in every
square centimeter over a million
microbes that are there to help protect
you against the environment and all the
things that are around you. So it's very
important to understand like what the
skin is, what's on it, what you need to
keep on it, and also the pH because if
you put the wrong thing on it, you can
screw that up and create the wrong
environment. you get the redness and
then you get rashes, you get acne, you
get dry skin, you have all sorts of
problems. Let's first talk about number
one, apple cider vinegar on your face.
Now, yes, it's acidic, but it is way,
way, way too acidic. I'm talking about
what some people do is they will put
straight undiluted apple cider vinegar
on their face. You're talking about a pH
that's down into like two to three,
which is like battery acid. that is so
acidic, you are going to create an
irritation and a redness on your face
that's not going to be good. So, you
don't want to put it on your face. In
fact, this is a side note, but we
sprayed apple cider vinegar on our grass
to kill some weeds. Not only did it kill
weeds, it killed all the grass like
within two days. So, you can imagine
what it does to your face. So, if you
were going to use apple cider vinegar
for some reason, you'd want to dilute
it. And I'm talking one teaspoon in a
whole 8 ounces of water. And then you
take that mixture and put on your face
if you're going to use it. But do not
use straight apple cider vinegar. Okay.
Number two, lemon or lime juice. You
don't want to put either of these on
your face or your hair. And the question
is why? Well, it contains a certain
phytonutrient chemical that will then
potentially create a problem if you go
out in the sun. Okay? And that condition
is called phyto phototo dermatitis.
Phyto is a plant-based chemical. This
one photo is the light or sun and then
dermatitis is inflammation of your skin.
In other words, certain things you don't
want to put on the skin and then go out
in the sun. Especially this one over
here. I'm going to jump to number four.
Bergamant, which is essential oil. I
think it's also even a perfume. You
wouldn't want to put that on your face
and then go out in the sun. There's a
known condition that creates
inflammation on the skin if you're
combining that with the sun. All right,
let's back up to number three. Essential
oils. There's a lot of different
essential oils that people are putting
on their skin that they probably
shouldn't put on their face, like cedar
wood or even tea tree oil. It's just too
strong. it's too concentrated and
there's a lot of other essential oils
that you have to be very careful with
because they're going to create an
irritation. One thing you could do is
try just a little bit on one part of
your face, just on that corner or
something to see if you react to it. But
you have to be very careful of these
super concentrated essential oils
because they have a lot of things in
them. Now, I think in other parts of
your body, you could probably use it
just fine, but be careful putting it on
your face. What about five? Baking soda.
What's wrong with that? Well, baking
soda has a pH of nine. Now, think about
this. We got neutral being seven and
then go from seven to 8. That's 10 times
more alkaline. And then from 8 to 9, now
we have a power of 10 * 10, which is
100. So, the pH of baking soda is 100
times more alkaline than seven. In other
words, we don't want to alkalize this
acidic skin because now the microbes are
not going to have the environment to
exist. So, you're going to create a
problem with this whole living
ecosystem. I mean, you can kind of look
at it like soil. Like, it needs to be
fertile. It needs to be healthy. So,
don't rub baking soda on your face.
Toothpaste in your face. Some people do
it. I don't know why they do it, but
toothpaste has some pretty harsh
chemicals for your teeth. Sometimes even
to pull stain off. Sometimes they use
hydrogen peroxide. Sometimes they use
fluoride. These things should not be put
on your face because sometimes people
put it on little different spots.
There's a much better thing that you can
put on these spots like for example
vitamin C serums or even the chemical
and aspirin. So don't be rubbing
toothpaste all over your face. Okay. All
right. Number seven, rubbing alcohol.
The problem with rubbing alcohol, I
mean, you could use it on different
parts of your body, but I would be very
careful rubbing on your face because
alcohol kills off microbes. It's
antimicrobial
and you have all these good bacteria on
your face that then you're going to kill
off and then allow for the overgrowth of
unfriendly bacteria to go on your skin.
And that's when you have things like
rosacea, like just redness and other
issues. But realize this, the more you
sterilize your face, the sicker the skin
will get. So, you don't want to be
putting rubbing alcohol. And this also
goes with different facial creams. Be
careful of buying these creams and
lotions and stuff with alcohol and then
applying to the face because not only
are they going to sterilize the face and
kill up the microbes and pasteurize your
face, but it's also going to dry your
face out as well. Hydrogen peroxide very
oxidizing and corrosive. It's good to
take stains off your teeth. It's good to
clean certain things, but do not put it
on your face, okay? Because it's too
concentrated and it can create a
bleaching effect that's not good. Not to
mention killing off the microbes, right?
Number nine, hair dye put on your
eyebrows or your eyelashes. The dye for
hair is very strong and it can be very
toxic if it can get into your eye. So,
if it leaks into the eye, there's been
even people that have gone blind or had
eye damage from that. So, be careful of
that on your face or your eyeballs.
Okay, I just wanted to add that in
there. Okay, number 10, topical
steroids. This is actually very common
for various parts of your face that are
red or irritated or flaky. It's kind of
like people don't even think twice about
it. A topical steroid, that's fine.
Topical steroids might be okay for
different parts of the body, but you
have to be very careful when putting it
on your face, especially if it's done
over and over again. You're dealing with
a steroid, a synthetic steroid that
literally shuts the immune system down
on your face. It gets rid of
inflammation. It's an anti-inflammatory
but at the same time it stops the growth
of skin cells. It stops the production
of collagen. So the big side effect is
thinning of the skin like your skin
becomes like paper thin. You start
seeing blood vessels. You start having
an overgrowth of unfriendly bacteria
because that's one of the side effects
because you're shutting down the immune
system. You get skin atrophy. So the
actual skin starts losing like I said
the collagen but also the skin cells.
You may even see stretch marks and
severe redness like rosacea and
increased pigment or loss of pigment on
the face. It's not good. I would be very
hesitant about using any type of topical
steroids on my face. And then number 11
is to use these exfoliating scrubs on a
daily basis. Again, you are scrubbing
off the microbiome off of your face.
You're taking away this protection of
your face and you're sterilizing it. So,
this can create a really big problem
with the health of your skin. Most
people think that healthy skin is a
sterilized clean, extra clean skin. So,
they scrub. And I used to do this when I
had acne in high school all the time.
And the more I did it, the worse my face
got. It became reddened and irritated
and more acne. There's nothing wrong
with doing a scrub, but just don't do it
every single day. Also, you want to get
a filter for your shower head to filter
out the chlorine and the fluoride
because that can be very damaging to the
skin as well. The last thing I want to
bring up is with makeup, overdoing with
makeup, using different foundations and
things like that. Just make sure that
you get a makeup that is as chemical
free as possible and is as fragrance
free as possible as well because those
fragrances are also toxic to the skin
microbiome. So now that I talked about
what to avoid on the skin, now you
should know the good things on your
skin. And for that information, you
should watch this video right here.
Check it out.